derek squibble on the mound
seven innings is the last time out is
four and seven and he's really coming
around
and on the first pitch here's a ball
stroke to center field by tim anderson
and he is on his way into second base oh
it happens fast in detroit
before our pants were wrinkled it's a
leadoff double
tim at second base and the o2 is
grounded to the right side so down 0-2
gavin makes something out of it at least
and pushes tim to third with one out
[Music]
and he's driven in by jose abreu
anderson scores sucks are up one-nothing
after a two-nothing lead in the first
yesterday
rbi 56 for jose who's had to take
another step forward rondale is out of
the lineup we don't know how many days
but with his disappearance from the
lineup jose becomes even a bigger factor
right side base hit for andrew vaughn
abreu cooks past second he's going for
third
and runners are at first and third
the shortstop a flat hop short to castro
and they'll only get the one out
abreu scores and garcia gets an rbi two
nothing again
in the first inning
dallas kykel out for his 16th start the
era a touch below four not gonna strike
out a lot of people not gonna walk a lot
of people
fastest guy in this lineup badou
strikes out swinging
[Applause]
wrapped to short the change up away does
exactly what dallas wants
and two down here in the bottom of the
first
another ground ball on the change up
burger on the move to sheets
charlotte knights rejoice
two nothing sucks
now their third run is just 90 feet away
with one away
the o2 swung on and foul tipped into the
glove of jake rogers the second
strikeout for terrex scuba is a biggie
here in the second that was big
maybe the space post
another 3-2
slow roller
scope off the bag
and scuba beats
sheets in a foot race to first
first bit of trouble for kykel who went
1-2-3 in the opening inning now it's
robbie grossman
on the ground tim it's short
turned by mendic there's a double play
six and four and three
two down cabrera to third
little q shot
danny mendick on the approach for sheets
and that will do it just as quickly as
trouble was brewing and sent away
into the ether billy hamilton leads off
the fourth
he struck him out start the four
just don't see what he does very often
the two two
and he gets collins looking an emphatic
strike three from tom hallian how about
doing
a chopper to third
high level for jammer candelario and the
white sox go one two three for the first
time against terrex school today two
walks in the inning
for dallas kykel
gary coss look at here his last 15 games
what is he looking for right now shep
fastball
the 01
[Applause]
has got the windmill going the throw
home not gonna get there
[Applause]
you call to gibby an inside the park
home run for eric haas and the tigers
have grabbed the lead
yeah let's watch it right in the second
right here
you feel the piano jumping back you just
gotta slow yourself down and pump your
arms relax
he actually was still running very well
3-2 tigers fifth inning
anderson one for two with a double in a
run
high change up to left field and down
all the way to the warning track it goes
tim skates for second for the second
time today and it's another leadoff
double for ta
and sets up an rbi situation for
the big man in the middle jose abreu
on the ground and through the drawn in
infield we are tied three all of rayu's
second driven in
he of course would have to be a long
base hit but nonetheless
he's got one driven in and he's got a
base hit
garcia on a fastball tags it to left
field forget a base hit how about a home
run five three socks that's the long
base hit yes the yuri just unloads on
one this is just the second time all
year that he's hit a home run he drives
in three today
sox have a two run lead he hit it 415
feet got every bit of
[Applause]
it bases are loaded
with nobody out and jonathan scope
walking
to the batter's box
bullet up the middle
one run is home
jake rogers hustling but his score and
we are tied at five thanks to jonathan
scopes clutch two-run single
here's jamer candelario
candelario to right field that's down
badou gets the windmill home he will
score the tigers lead it jammer
candelario with an rbi single
6'5 detroit
here comes the payoff
and he walks in a run
so joe jimenez comes in the ball game
for the 22nd time his era is way up
there the sox trail by a pair
he struck him out to start the sixth
that fielder's by himself
oh
collins sits down
[Applause]
the o2
that's nice
he strikes out the side
two swinging one looking
first and second for eric haas
the 1-1
fly ball right field garcia going back
still going back it's gone
his second three run both of the day
trying to get it in they left their
middle
he didn't roll that over he put backspin
to right
in the catch by a pan
[Applause]
here's jonathan skope
they've had the biggest hit for the
tigers today in the fifth the two run
single
oh scope slams one deep center field
that goes hamilton still going back
that's into the bushes
that's a strong man
11-5 tigers
boy look how he stands there even though
it's center field he knows it he when
you hit her like that you feel it
he knew it he stood up but then he said
this is comerica i better start running
and that's way out 440
feet
for jonathan scope
and his 16th homer of the year
crowd is loving it they're great
thanks for coming
brown ball to third candelario on the
charge nice win for detroit
11 runs 10 hits
three bombs two by erik haas